ethics is based on the greek word ethos
ethos
culture is an expression
of the ethos or the atmosphere that is
established through ethics the unwritten
rules of a group of people
our culture
is able to establish a consent based
understanding
of artificial intelligence
the outcomes of ai are so much better
if we feed it with data given with
consent
as opposed to just taking the data
without consent
we at ibm have written these rules as
part of our ethical principles
now apart from consent
a culture that nurtures responsible ai
truly values diversity and inclusivity
ai fx remember is a team sport
exclusion breeds elitism that in turn
breeds the very toxic notion that one
human being is better than another human
being
we actually know via this mathematical
model
that the wider the variance the more
standard the mean or put another way the
more diverse a group of people actually
trying to tackle a really complicated
problem
the less chance for error so it's really
important to consider things like
gender
race ethnicity age neurodiversity
worldview skill set as you're starting
your team so now that you've got this
amazingly diverse team what next
remember earning trust and artificial
intelligence is not a technological
challenge it's a socio-technological
challenge
so this it's really important to adopt
frameworks for systemic empathy
we have a map we have exercises we have
design thinking as a means to do this
and we use this approach to generate
artificial intelligence that is
intentional in its efforts to augment a
human being
we have an amazing design thinking
practice
our design practice is based
on what is somebody thinking
seeing hearing and doing
the very expression of culture
about 80 percent of efforts in
artificial intelligence actually get
stuck in proof of concept and this is
for a wide variety of different kinds of
reasons
some of the top ones
are that
often oftentimes
the investments in the ai aren't tied
directly to business strategy or people
simply don't trust the results of the
model so we actually use design thinking
to walk both c-suite as well as
technologists through four different
stages
we start with intent
what is the intent behind the investment
in this ai model and how is it tied
directly to strategy
we identify
the sources of data that they have
access to and how it is being collected
we evaluate
the data sources and the effects of the
proposed ai model
and
we plan
how to roll out the effort
in the evaluate phase we embed
frameworks for systemic empathy called
tech ethics by design on an as needed
basis this is based on three different
steps the first step is called layers of
effect
it looks kind of like this
right these would be your primary and
your secondary effects both
intended and known
and this third one
is actually tertiary effects
unintended and possibly known effects of
your ai model and this is actually where
your team of people who will be doing
this workshop together will actually
might be coming up with ideas on what
could potential harm look like right so
it's really important you've got the
right people in the room
the second
step
for tech ethics by design is called
dichotomy mapping
and in this step you take these ideas
around potential tertiary effects again
unintended and possibly known and you
split them up into what could be
potentially beneficial
and what could
be potentially harmful
okay
and then the third step
is called ethical hacking
in this step
the first thing to do as an organization
is think about what are your principles
for artificial intelligence
again what is your ethos
what are you going to stand by
the second step right so again these are
principles or values
then this part is
given these principles given these
values what are the rights of the
individual what are the rights of the
end user
and then given that given those rights
and this particular harm which might
have come up in the prior example in the
prior step
how would
a team how would your team mitigate
against any potential harm so that it's
actually you're designing intentionally
in order to protect against this this
particular harm
i cannot underscore enough how valuable
this framework is it has really unlocked
true epiphanies on teams
in closing
we have the ability to set up the
correct ethos right the the ethical
standards to augment humans and truly
democratize artificial intelligence
in order to achieve
systemic equity in ai
we need to work with truly diverse teams
right
and the way that these folks work
together is to use design thinking to
tie
ai models to business intent and crack
the empathy code well before any
programming code is written
thank you
if you like this video and series please
comment below
stay tuned for more videos that are part
of this series and to get updates please
like and subscribe